On your quest to find love, and
possibly have offspring, many of us cringe at the idea of mating with a sibling or any relative really, weird.
But what's the big problem with incest in the first place?
What actually happens when you inbreed? The first thing to understand is how any trait you have comes about. You have your
biological mom and your dad who each have their own unique DNA. And,
basically, you get half of your DNA from mom and half from dad. These DNA pairs define everything about you,
but in some cases, certain traits are more
dominant; like brown eyes for example. If your mom has two pairs of the brown eye allele, her eyes will be brown, and if your
dad has two pairs for the blue eyes,
his will be blue as a result, you'll receive one brown gene from mom and one blue
gene from dad but brown eyes just happened to be a dominant trait meaning even though you get one brown and one blue from each parent, your eye color will actually be brown. It takes having two
recessive alleles to exhibit the other traits in this case if you got two blue alleles,
you'd end up having blue eyes. So what does this have to do with incest it turns out that many specific diseases,
or disorders, are recessive and require you to get the gene from both your mother and father.
They can each carry one and be perfectly healthy, making it difficult to know that they are
carriers. As a result, if your dad has one allele for a disorder
it's pretty likely that his sibling or relative probably has it too because they would have gotten it from their parents or other
relatives had your dad decided to mate with a random person in the population, the chance of them having the same recessive
gene is low, but if he chooses to copulate with his sister, or cousin,
then your odds of getting both of the recessive genes are much higher; still not guaranteed,
but much more likely. In that sense
It's important to remember that inbreeding doesn't create genetic mutations or defective offspring itself, but instead
increases the chance of a rare gene combination in fact even when both parents carry a recessive gene,
there's still a 75% chance that they won't both pass on the gene leading to perfectly healthy kids with respect to that particular
disorder or disease. So, is inbreeding ever good? Not so much in humans,
but we rely on it in some plants and animals; in fact different dog breeds are the result of reading?
relatives with similar desirable traits, like coat color, height, or snout size,
but we can even see the risk in dogs with many purebred suffering from hip problems,
eye problems, and more; while mutts or dogs with genetically diverse parents tend to be healthier.
Thanks for tuning in to our video, that's (that is) kind of about incest. We really hope that you enjoyed it
there's science in everything people. Not just kind of incest, it was fully about incest. Yeah,
fully about incest. If you want to watch more of our videos. We'll put some extras over here.
Also, make sure you subscribe to our channel, and we will see you next week for another video, peace!